eher sternberg sie stehen im impfzentrum
bei ihnen was war da los was ist da los
und was wird da los sein
ja ich hoffe ihr wird bald ganz viel los
sein denn im moment ist hier wirklich
wenig los wir haben im kapazitäten
aufgebaut von bis zu 1500 impfungen am
tag 350 pro im zentrum und dann mobile
teams für den ländlichen raum
organisiert wir haben lange mit der
landesregierung über das konzept
gesprochen und jetzt bin ich seit tagen
eigentlich die person an der spitze des
landkreises die entscheiden muss mit dem
wenigen impfdosen wäre dann zuerst dran
ist und das sorgt natürlich in der
bevölkerung für eine wirklich schwierige
situation und man machen sie da sie
nicht und ich hätte wenn der impfstoff
so gekommen wäre wieder zum anfang
zugesagt worden wäre letzten freitag
hier im landkreis mit ein pfleger
einrichtungen und krankenhäusern durch
sein können das tut er aber nicht dann
wenn ich so wie für die letzte woche in
900 dosen zur verfügung habe für den
zweitgrössten flächenland kreis und
deutschland und nächste woche nur 350
dann wissen sie in welcher situation wir
sind und ich will noch mal eins ganz
deutlich sagen auch in richtung herr
lindner
ich kann es nicht mehr hören dass
darüber gesprochen wird dass wir nicht
vorbereitet sind berlin muss die
hausaufgaben machen und mir ist auch
ehrlich gesagt egal welche partei das
ist denn wir sind hier vor ort ich fange
das ab und ich sage ihnen ich kann als
landrat nicht mal mehr einkaufen gehen
weil jeder hat eine traurige geschichte
einer oma einer tante einer mama eines
papas der geimpft werden muss der
transplantierten organe hat der eine
krebserkrankung hinter sich hat das ist
hochgradig frustrierend was gerade
passiert und ich bin ganz doll
unglücklich berlin war noch nie so weit
weg obwohl es nur zwei autostunden sind
von ludwigslust parchim gehen diesen
wochen so man braucht nicht mehr mit der
kommunalen ebene reden weil also
natürlich sollten wir immer miteinander
reden aber ich hab so ein bisschen das
gefühl dass hier auch ein stück weit auf
uns abgeschoben werden soll wir sind
vorbereitet hätten
man hat mit uns gesprochen wir haben mit
den hausärzten gesprochen unsere
ministerpräsidentin trifft sich mit uns
alle 14 tage in einem sogenannten mv
gipfel dass also das ist ein schritt zu
spät
den brauchen wir nicht mehr wir brauchen
den schritt
stoff in deutschland für die
risikogruppen und dann kann unsere
gesellschaft auf wieder anfangen alles
andere was wir hier diskutieren
das ist richtig aber es sind doch zum
teil nebel gefechte und das geht ja gar
nicht nur gegen herrn lindner bitte
nicht falsch verstehen oder gar nicht
gegen händen
wir brauchen klarheit wir brauchen
verlässliche liefermengen damit die
unsere bürger ein bestellen können weil
am ende bin ich der landrat deren ein
pflegeheim wo 120 menschen leben 96 aus
brücke hat und 20 todesopfer und ich
muss es verantworten